brother passed his dad at a funeral
why my grandma passed away there was a
funeral people have been grieving the
whole week it's the last day the last
thing they did was do some prayer with
like incense and stuff everybody's just
dressed in normal clothing but my dad
and uncles were wearing these white
garments over that at the end of it my
brother goes up to my dad and pulls his
pants down me and my mom look at each
other and we're like you know how you're
like you're not supposed to laugh at a
funeral but like I had to like walk out
of the room in his 20s like he was fully
grown is this his thing that he does why
no he's just his thing I don't know what
caused him to just go up to my dad in
front of everybody and just go like this
listen people deal with grief
differently what did your dad do right
after that he ignored it because he he
was just like sad even funnier because
his mom just died and he's like pass
around his ankles
by his 20 something year old